Very difficult situation.
Israel
is bombing the civilian population of Gaza.
It has already killed 2,750 civilians,
1,030 of them children.
Has imposed a regime
absolutely illegal,
blocking access to electricity,
food,
to construction materials,
to fuel.
They have decreed a blackout
so that you can't see what is going on there.
The President you met last week
to give him their support,
has said that it is total war,
that there are no war laws on this,
that not a single civilian is safe
in until everyone is guilty.
Madam President,
you have met with him to give him your support,
but it cannot do so on behalf of this parliament.
This parliament
has to occur about such a serious situation,
a situation that is
a holocaust over the Palestinian population.
We cannot maintain minutes of silence
by the Israeli victims
and not to do so on the Palestinians